so the second block in a row
okay unpleasant once again should
probably survive somehow
uh let's play i don't know
let's play b5 maybe
i think it's considered to be bad after
e4 knight xc4 bishop takes b5 but i
think my argument has played it even in
a
probably in a classical game against
someone very strong
like arowana maybe so then it should
probably do for a glitch game
should we play c5
let's try to play bishop d6
this may look a little strange but
actually it's a typical idea so
sometimes in uh
in the london system black places e6
bishop d6 with the pawn on d7
the point is that uh
yeah i don't know what's the point to be
honest but maybe there is some point
yeah 92 now i guess we go knight 697 to
bring the knight closer
the problem is normally you get this
position with the pawn on b6 and the
yeah the pawn structure is way less
and way less vulnerable and here i think
why it will be c3 queen in 2a4 and
yeah try to attack my queen side
eventually
yeah he goes c3
and he goes e4 which i think is uh
sort of inspiring for us
let's try to play ninja six first
starts on ignite f4 in some lines
and he goes e5 which allows many things
knight f4 is one of them for instance
okay let's go knight f4
it's not a big drama just play uh bishop
f1 but still
i don't think you're too happy is white
to play
bishop d3 to f1 here and otherwise i
think it's
sort of risky for him
yeah he does go with super fun
so is there a fancy way to place this
somehow
um yeah maybe not really actually
all right then i guess we just take
and go knight h5 or even knight g8 maybe
95 is also possible of course but then i
don't like knight f4
which is still not the end of the world
obviously but the knight is coming to d6
which i would prefer to avoid
okay let's go on ij8 actually
so it's a slow plan but if it works i
mean it's uh
yeah i mean if it works it's very
ambitious i want to play 97 queen c7 and
attack uh yeah attack
e5 in those lines
i also didn't have regular squares so
knight f2d5 would allow
94 knight h5 uh
would mean um
yeah you know in a worry about my knight
some g3 or g4
could use there and now i just go back
and um back in e5
and i yeah yeah i managed to to avoid
blundering's knight which is also
very decent all right 27
so if i was hanging i think
like he can probably cut long now
but that's at least yeah i mean at least
a sacrifice i can take on a5 knight
takes e5 bishop takes h1
looks scary but um
i can do it so he goes from g1
because of that okay let's just go
knight to seven knights of six maybe
yeah he goes h4 we just think he lost 96
and we finally managed to collect the
pawn
alright so can we
can we just take we can also before
maybe
just for fun
and yeah the problem is that there is no
need to include before but
yeah i want to do it for some reason
okay let's include before
[Music]
yeah he goes c4 i expected him to you
have to go c4 actually
knight c4 is probably even better but
then at least we get some um
yeah some potential for
um for some tactics i would say
so we can take on c396 king of fate
b take c3 and then come up with
something like net xc5
which i guess doesn't work but
it could actually work with uh
[Music]
with the king on s7 okay let's try this
so he just takes back
96 now i guess we take 25
and now we go check
like at very least we can take on f3 win
a1 is also there
i don't know let's just take takes
knight
and
and i don't know queen e7 maybe
that's a blunder but it was really bad
for white anyway
okay here's ants thanks for the game
uh what else do we have
we actually have a stronger guys
who want to play with an increment so i
realized after yeah after the previous
time i realized i'll never
[Music]
probably never play um
result increment here again so